suite avec meriem laribi et les
journalistes de la rédaction web de rt
france est tout de suite c'est rt sur le
web
[Musique]
bonjour meriem ravi de vous retrouver
sur rt france ce matin l'administration
tonnes trunk a donc récemment placé cuba
sur la liste noire des pays soutenant le
terrorisme c'est une décision qui a
provoqué l'indignation et la
condamnation d'un certain nombre de pays
myriem quelles réactions avez vous
retenu dans votre article
oui bonjour à tous les deux la russie le
venezuela la chine ainsi que les rangs
on croit au condamné cette décision du
gouvernement américain sortant prises
neuf jours à peine avant la fin du
mandat de donald trump
la russie a dénoncé une démarche à
caractère non constructifs et a fait
notamment référence au rôle diplomatique
joué par cuba dans la réconciliation
nationale en colombie la chine a estimé
pour sa part que la décision a été sans
fondement et qu'elle décridibiliser les
états unis même chose pour l'iran qui a
assuré être aux côtés de cuba dans sa
résistance contre le symbole de
l'arrogance mondiale
le porte-parole de la diplomatie
iranienne a en outre estimé que ce sont
les états unis d'amérique qui
soutiennent de nombreuses organisations
terroristes même chose pour le venezuela
qui a condamné fermement cette décision
prise contre la république soeur de cuba
alors meriem barack obama avait retiré
cuba du cette histoire en 2015
pourquoi donald trump at il décidé de la
remettre à la fin de son mandat c'est la
question que beaucoup se posent comme
vous l'avez dit beaucoup décisions
viennent d'être prises en dernière
minute
certains observateurs estiment que
donald trump pratiquer la politique de
la terre brûlée pour contrarier son
successeur joe biden qui fut en ce qui
concerne cuba notamment le vice
président d'obama en prenant donc
plusieurs décisions de dernière minute
biden pendant sa campagne a fait des
déclarations contradictoires concernant
au cuba il avait assuré qu'il
renverserait les politiques de donald
trump
à propos de l'île socialistes mees
aussi déclaré avoir affronté pendant son
mandat de vice-président
les castro et les poutines de ce monde
toujours est il que si biden veut
retirer un nouveau cuba de la liste il
faudra de longues procédures juridiques
afin qu'ils puissent le faire trump aura
donc réussi à le retarder dans cette
démarche et meriem concrètement qu'est
ce que cette décision va changer pour
cuba au delà de la stigmatisation
supplémentaire finalement ça ne va pas
changer grand chose pour cuba qui est
sous le coup d'un embargo sévère depuis
des décennies le placement sur cette
liste noire un pic des sanctions comme
une interdiction des d'économique
américaine une interdiction des
transferts d'argent entre les deux pays
est une obligation pour les états unis
de s'opposer aux prêts accordés qui
pourrait être accordée à cuba par des
institutions telles que la banque
mondiale ou le fonds monétaire
international
cela étant bon nombre de ces
restrictions sont déjà en place du fait
de l'embargo économique américain qui a
été lourdement renforcée par donald
trump
cet embargo qui étouffe littéralement
l'économie cubaine ne peut être relevé
que par le congrès des états unis
merci beaucoup meriem l'arrivée je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
ouais pour rt france on peut retrouver
vos articles sur notre site arte france
- pb